hello and welcome to google developers
live my name is Arun Nagarajan and I'm
from the google apps developer relations
team and today we have a special guest
gliffy that's going to be joining here
the studios and they've actually built a
great google docs add-on that they're
going to walk us through but before we
dive into some of the demos and details
let's actually let them introduce
themselves I have Luba and Han hi I'm a
software developer at Gliffy and I've
been working on to a doll for about a
month now and it's been really great
awesome i'm han lee i'm a product lead
at Gliffy and i've been working with
Luba to get our app put together great
and for the folks that are not familiar
with gliffy can you give me a background
on what the company does but the product
is sure absolutely Goofy's of fast and
easy to use diagramming tool we were
founded in 2005 and where the world's
first net native diagramming app are we
started out in flash and ported to html5
about a year and a half ago gliffy works
and because it's html5 Gliffy works on
platforms anywhere where chrome is
supported so mac pc linux chrome OS and
personally i really love working with
the html5 technology awesome and who is
a typical user of Gliffy it varies a lot
so we we support a number of diagram
types a typical diagram would be a
flowchart like this one an erd diagram
like this or fun diagrams this is
something one of our users put together
for a diagramming contest cool very cool
all right so why don't we actually take
a look at the actual add-on and then
we'll kind of dig into some of the
technical details and talk a bit about
some of the experience you've had okay
so we have a Gliffy menu drop-down and
if you have existing diagrams all you
got to do is just click on find and
it'll pull up a list of the recent
diagrams that you've been working on and
you can insert it directly from there
and you can always browse by folder if
you have you know diagram Co Dolph
there's also a search feature and then
you could also edit the diagrams
directly from the sidebar and it will
open up the gliffy interface the
full-featured interface additionally you
could create a new diagram from google
dogs and that will offer you some
templates and after you create it and
then you would save it and you would be
able to hopefully see it in the document
that's great and this is just another
tab in your browser exactly and then
once it successfully saves and then if
you go back to this it will refresh
every 30 seconds and you will be able to
see it that's great so it's like just
checking behind the scenes for new
documents yeah that's great so you don't
have to really think about it too much
it basically pulls in all the recent
diagrams assuming that you might want
one that's great there it is yeah go
ahead and insert it cool I like the way
you've done the overlay menus there yeah
bootstrap help that's great so that
actually gets to our next point which is
can you talk a little bit about some of
the technology seaview some of the
internals of how this all works what
some of the salient points are ya so
there are technical background it's very
simple for this add-on we have a few
HTML templates that we use and just one
controller that actually governs and
takes care of all the HTML templates and
of course we have the server script that
talks to the gliffy server that's pretty
much it that's great and you use
bootstrap here for the styling and every
yeah bootstrap is was a big Savior okay
that's great and other special
considerations you guys can do effect
for the sidebar design from aux
standpoint we had a we had our designers
help us out to make sure that it lays
out and it reflects basically the gliffy
interface as well as matches what Google
would might might want so a lot of the
buttons are actually a lot very similar
to I could call you up very nice very
nice what are some of the interesting
challenges you ran into some of the
things that gave you grief or was
complicated that you could share with us
for me it was really easy lupa did all
the hard way yeah I'm sure them sure
there's some interesting challenges yeah
so we did have some kajal limitations
that we ran into i wasn't expecting to
not have certain things available but
the workarounds were usually very simple
and just required a little bit of
investigation that's great what would be
your advice to other add-on developers
out of other developers that are
interested in writing
tools for Google Docs or sheets I would
advise them to make a UI heavy
application and to limit the script to
just the bare bones mainly because you i
have e ad on wood me a more responsive
user experience that's great and by that
you mean do more things that Dava script
in the sidebar softly that's right
sometimes that meant I would write
hidden HTML elements that would store
some data but it was such a worthwhile
trade off interesting versus going back
to the survey of catching something
interesting very interesting so when you
launch this what are some of the
interesting success metrics that you'll
be tracking what are some of the things
that would mean important launch
milestones for you that's a great
question i'm very metrics focused so 11
key one would be the number of the
percent of our regular users that
actually use the app so that'll give us
an idea of the popular a new within our
user base another one is the conversion
rate of new users so we would take a
look at people coming in through the
marketplace built into Google Docs and
compare the conversion rate to our other
ecosystems great that's great I've had a
fun time using the ad on myself
gleefully is a really fun to use tool
it's one of those tools that you just
open a tab and start sketching right
it's great for brainstorm and great for
architecture diagrams for software
systems and things like that google has
Google drawings but I feel like goofy
has got some really good templates and
really good capabilities that I think
it's useful for anyone in any industry
so best of luck with the launch I urge
you all to go test this and try this
add-on and thank you very much for being
this video with us thank you so much
thanks super thank you